[Applause]
[Music]
they make you
like feel badly so you say to your wife
you say to your husband darling let's go
after dinner and then we'll come back we
love our president
but you know the polls say he can't win
well right
i'm soaking wet already suppression
falls
suppression falls in the name of jesus
from south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming
[Music]
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
[Music]
[Music]
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you
they don't want to know the truth well
you probably know the truth
okay so so there's rudy passing gas
but the content of this was also
disgusting this went on for hours
[Music]
single witness just like you they don't
want to know the truth
well you probably know the truth
[Music]
why don't you look at the registered
voters on there
how many registered voters are on there
did you even know the answer to that i'm
trying to get this all right welcome
everybody um
i just saw the funniest comment oh hold
on am i on hello oh i'm on
i just saw the funniest um comment
on twitch from house of leaves saying
these song makers have
sunk to a new low i feel like the songs
have gotten to a new high like i feel
like early on we were only starting to
sort of understand
the scope of how funny these songs can
be
and now we're actually getting to the
songs being good
uh but that's uh that's just a
disagreement that's just a gentleman's
disagreement i
i'm sorry i'm sort of running late i i
assume joe biden's also running very
late so it should be okay we're
potentially going to get
some major cabinet and administration
announcements today
and we're going to look at the
triggering that is taking place with
donald trump
it's just been a hectic hectic day i'm
in the bunker
um i just had a really strong meeting
with our accountant
and the news was not great uh what we
basically were able to determine
in our meeting with the accountant was
we may
be running out of memberships we
actually may be out of memberships
soon and you know one of the things our
accountant
um does is we don't talk politics he
just advises me
as to how he believes tax law will
change
and he said he does believe any
discounts
off above 60 percent will be illegal
uh if the biden administration is given
an opportunity to weigh in on that so
the combination
of being almost out of uh memberships
and the discounts being illegal to me
signals
it's it's time it's time to get those
memberships so i've got a few different
things actually i have a ton of things
to talk about here
uh where to even begin so
there are folks who um saw my appearance
the other day
with stephen kenneth destiny
bennell ii in terms of he reviewed some
of the songs
actually he reviewed the jethro bradley
rudy
giuliani fart song and he got sick of it
after like 10 seconds and his viewers
were demanding it continue so i think
that that's something we could be
looking at but
it seems that there is a sort of rift to
the destiny pacman arc
and it's really a disagreement over the
quality of some of these songs and i
take that as a personal
uh as a personal insult because these
the songs are strong
so that's that um but we're gonna be
looking at that in the future now i do
have
do do you guys want me to do i have a
crazy new troy york
voicemail to play i also
have a correction and you know the
corrections are very rare on this
program not because i have any
ideological
opposition to correcting things i get
wrong but because i quite frankly just
get things wrong so infrequently
that there's very very little to correct
but i do actually have a correction to
issue
that's partially a joke but i do make
every effort to get things right
and i have oh no i thought i had a new
jimmy from philly voicemail but i don't
i have a troy york voicemail but not a
jimmy from philly voicemail
um and then continued questions about my
zucchini and that's going to be
something
something we look at later okay so i
will do i'll do the correction in a
moment i do want to read through a few
super chats here
sam dean from australia says there are
reports trump has lost 135 000 twitter
followers and biden gained a million in
that time i believe that that is the
same thing i saw
massachusetts native says bigly massive
dumps cause
clogged plumbing at white house um
this is kind of a gross super chat i'm
gonna skip the rest of it
and leela ramsey says david you're aging
so slowly do you wear daily sunscreen or
are you just immortal that's very nice
of you to say
uh no it's it's botox botox is what it
is
and um i talk about that further on the
uh
bonus show which summer summer may be
referring now to as the boner show which
is a weird
name for it quite frankly all right let
me let me issue my correction
um yesterday we did a bigly viral clip
where kaylee marganani
gets some math uh completely wrong
actually is this the one yeah it is and
i made a sort of unclear
arguably incorrect statement in my
analysis so let's let's listen
and i'm guys i'm sorry that we're not
seeing the super chats on screen it's
because i've got a different stream set
up today and i've just not been figured
been able to figure out based on the
having only two monitors instead of five
i have
wait one two three four no hold on three
four
one two three yeah i have four monitors
in my normal setup
and i just i'm not able to put them on
screen but i am seeing them okay so one
thing at a time let's listen to kaylee
for tried type of election with the mail
and voting and what this lawsuit does
uh it looks at those anomalies and
here's what it finds it finds that the
chances
of biden coming from as far behind as he
was at 3 a.m on election night
the chances of that are one in one
quadrillion
the chances of him that that's
prevailing in one state prevailing in
all four of the states where he was so
far behind the chances of that
are one in a quadrillion to the fourth
power okay so the other day i did an
analysis
or yesterday and this clip did
beautifully well
where i explained that you know what
kaylee is assuming when she says the
chance
of what happened happening is one in one
quadrillion
what she means is that
biden losing on election night and then
ending up winning with mail in votes
would only happen in one
out of one quadrillion simulations with
the inputs that we had
and of course it wrongly assumes that
because
biden won for example biden won
pennsylvania 50 to 49
and what she means is if you assume
every city every county
mail in in person if you assume and
expect everything to be 50 49
then it would be weird what happened
when you understand like hey it was 85
it was like 83 17
in philly and that was like a huge
county and malen went to buy
once you understand that one in one
quadrillion doesn't make any sense but
where i went wrong was that i also just
plainly said that's also not how
exponents work when she says
in one state the odds are one and one
quadrillion in four
states it's one in one quadrillion
raised to the fourth power
i i should have been more clear because
theoretically that is how you would
you would look at a cut the likelihood
of two
of two independent events both happening
and if you believe each one of them is
one in one quadrillion you would raise
it to the fourth power so i
i was wrong and confusing when i simply
said that's not how exponents work
i should have better clarified that
given that one in one quadrillion is
wrong
and also the idea that it would be one
in one quadrillion
in four different states states that
have different populations and different
margins
given all of that you can't just put
raise it to the fourth power and say
that's your number
i wasn't clear about that theoretically
that is how exponents would work
of course all the actual uh uh or math
of it was wrong and therefore
it's not in practice how it would work
okay so i that's my apology
i was unclear about that i want to say
thanks to amelia pancakes
shelbs texas ian snyder
for gifting and subscribing that's four
as well as um
soleil 95 cashmere
ansel uh which puts us at
um at seven
new members all new members and twitch
subs already
also big thank you to zoe finkelson for
signing up on my website
robert glassford and jordan anderson
that's numbers
eight nine and ten which puts us at ten
okay good
so we're standing by here for joe biden
at the bottom of the hour
expecting some very very important
announcements in terms of cabinet and
administration selections
i've been keeping an eye on the uh joe
biden youtube channel
to see if we can get a stream there and
we do have one beautiful
okay so just a couple of other little
things
uh we are seeing
the wrong shot here we go we are seeing
heavy triggering
from donald trump um some of the things
he's uh been
been uh tweeting um now it turns out the
democrats want to pack the court with 26
justices
hold on a second i should actually go
uh let me change this to dark mode i
know a lot of people really don't like
this let me go to dim
there we go sorry about that i know that
that that's bad for a lot of people here
we go
uh donald trump tweeting oh this
now that the biden administration this
is the first time i've
ever seen donald trump use that term
biden administration
so we are inching closer and closer to a
concession as i pointed out here
but it's still not really one because he
wants it stolen now that the biden
administration will be a scandal-plagued
mess for years to come it is much easier
for the supreme court of the united
states to follow the constitution
and do what everybody knows has to be
done they must show great correction
wisdom
save the usa i still don't know why
trump capitalizes random
non-proper nouns in the middle of
sentences great courage and wisdom why
is that capitalized i'll i'll never know
but um of course this is very very
dangerous
trump is apparently saying that the
right thing is for the
the supreme court to give the election
to the candidate that didn't win which
seems very wrong
trump again referencing his so-called
perfect
phone call to ukraine
uh which is just idiotic trump saying he
wants the world to stop
uh he just wants to stop the world from
killing itself
which is crazy he again went after
the obama administration over swine flu
and of course swine flu was everything
about swine flu is different
it wasn't nearly as deadly as
coronavirus it doesn't really make any
sense
bragging about no war with korea and
then retweeting
is this oa yet hold on what is this
greg kelly chain of custody what is this
um
seals serial numbers were missing pull
pads were tagged
correctly for my poll but they were
programmed
for adams park library which was over 25
miles away
i mean it's like they're just going and
going and going it never stops
then posting some kind of greg kelly
video graduated from
law school but unfortunately for him it
was all downhill from there
look the whole country knows about his
issues but the mainstream media
refused to tell you about them minimized
it they went along with the whole oh
it's
russia collusion it's russia
disinformation so let me let me oh
my god this do do i should i even be
talking like do we want to even want to
hear about this
this whole uh thing with hunter i guess
i'll just briefly mention it so
what what the right wing media is now
claiming is that the hunter biden laptop
from hell story was accurate all along
but that the corporate mainstream media
wasn't willing to talk about it until
after biden won
this is the claim they're making they're
saying you know the story that
hunter biden flew across the country
to have a legally blind guy fix his
laptops
and he went straight from the airport to
this to this blind guy to do the laptops
um drunk and then he left the laptops
and never went and picked them up and
then the blind guy
uh looked instead of trying to trying to
just return the laptops
he accessed the private files of hunter
biden
and found emails that exposed joe biden
and sent it to the fbi
but when the fbi didn't do anything to
his liking
the blind computer repairman called rudy
giuliani
that's the story okay what what they are
now
saying is that was accurate all along
and now corporate media
is willing to talk about it because the
election's over okay
the truth is what's going on now with
hunter biden has nothing to do with that
hunter biden uh is having uh has a lien
that has been placed because he
allegedly underpaid his taxes by a
hundred thousand dollars and now he's
delinquent on those hundred thousand
dollars
okay has nothing to do with the laptop
from hell
has nothing to do with with joe biden
obviously
it has nothing to do with any of these
things and
the difference between now and before
the election
is that there's actually evidence for
this story that that's the actual
difference
um and that's why uh that that's why i
mean
i also reported on the hunter by we
talked about it yesterday on the bonus
show
so um that i mean let's just leave it
there i don't think we have to go on and
say anything else
okay other super chats coming in chaka
seki says
i just used the coupon code flesh chart
and it pulled up illicit nudes of trump
is the code illegal the code is
completely illegal but the actual code
is fresh start
not flesh shart important to know the
right code
david i watched your video on the
secretary of defense as a black
progressive you are not racist
you were right it's a reversion to the
mean that's from chalkway pitchford
appreciate that
very much appreciate that uh that
message chocoy
thank you so much um also uh via
a twitch i want to say thank you to
modo grinder who has just grabbed
a twitch prime sub and is number 11.
and jamie mcmahon has signed up at
jointpakman.com and is number 12.
okay do we want to do the um guys i i
understand you can't see
the uh oh so i guess trump just tweeted
something hold on let's see what did he
just tweet
what is this
antonio mohica and his partner alfredo
anzola received a small business loan
from the venezuelan
government only months before the recall
election these corporate registration
documents from venezuela show the
venezuelan government
owned 28 of the stock of another company
they started
vista which adapted voting software for
the smartmatic machines in the 2004
elections
the same document shows a chavez
government minister
omar montio was on the board of
directors the chavez government gained
vista smartmatic and another company
it's funny because like they they're so
so they're using this connection to
claim joe biden didn't really win i
guess
um trump retweeting what melissa tate
said i don't know who that is
joe biden will not set foot in the white
house 170 000 votes in michigan have
just been discovered to not have a trace
to a registered voter in michigan
if you guys weren't aware that claim
about election fraud is disputed
very weird stuff really really weird
stuff um okay
let me get the uh let me play i'll play
this voicemail we got another voicemail
from troy york and he's upset that i'm
not debating people i've never heard of
take a listen to this you might
you might like this yeah you don't uh
debate
you don't uh debate the hodge twins you
don't
okay so i don't know who the hodge twins
are just i have no clue who that is
that's number one let's continue
debate stephen crowder okay i know who
stephen crowder is it's not clear he's
much for debating
uh uh left-wing people longer with
crowder you don't debate
jp sears jp sears i have no idea who
that is
you just don't debate you're scared to
debate pacman
all you ever have on your show are
fellow liberals
libtards
you are scared to debate you don't have
these men on you
you don't have the red elephants the red
elephants i don't know who that is
vincent james on vincent james never
heard of him
you don't debate you don't debate
my my my david pakman the argentine
israeli troll
don't debate i'm not i am jewish i'm not
israeli let's let's
remember that you
are a joke you that say nothing about
gavin newsom and the con creeping
communism
yeah gavin newsom's advocating for the
government to own all business
of these lockdowns and he wants sugar
rations too
things attack on their capitalist system
you you you you hate america you you
know i want america to be better
i'm born here you want it to be weakened
like
it is true that i wasn't born here he's
right he's right about that
argentina you want socialism you want
one party state
nope i don't i'm not a socialist don't
want a one-party state i want more
parties not fewer
you want uh a country like chile
i don't know that much about chile but
so that's just weird i've never been and
don't know that much about it
uh you want like venezuela definitely
not no
don't want a country like venezuela what
tyranny left-wing charity like nicholas
medulla
nope i'm i'm against maduro in fact i
get sometimes critiqued by by some of my
further left viewers who say why don't i
like maduro i don't like maduro because
i'm not an authoritarian leftist
oh you want chile before i land with
how they were with salvador and londy
allende
oh my god of course of course he's
speaking about
salvador as as we say in argentina we
would say ashinde
or ayende how did he pronounce that a
lundy me get that hold on where are we
before i land with alex a linguist
yeah before at one point did you guys
know chile was led by a radical linguist
cunning by the way with salvador and
londy
you you you want latin american type
style dictatorship in america no in fact
many of my viewers criticize me that i
don't want that
and president trump and the republicans
and conservatives will continue to
resist
by any means necessary so there's the
latest news
from uh from troy york and then i think
i do
have a uh this is a troy york
voicemail songified by jethro bradley
let's listen to it
should i play this this is one of the
most vile callers we have
take a listen to the i have not
pre-screened this so i let me just warn
you
this may not be suitable for children
for children
oh no this isn't troy york this is the
prickles caller
now that your uh your hero is there are
you gonna sit there in your little
kimono and where your little hat
is right because it's going to be called
no free speech red chinese communist
speech but you can't have pork because
you might offend the ayatollahs
after all you're gonna love this too
you're gonna make a bomb and i hope they
drop it right on your freaking ass
but you can't have pork but you can't
have pork
you but you can't have pork flakes
anyway so uh particularly in the spirit
of
chanukah brisket i will not be having
any pork today
um so that was not that was not troy
yorke
that was prickless guy and um
uh yeah i see people asking about
whether law enforcement ever gets
involved with these people
i uh i don't know i have a story i could
tell but i try not to tell these stories
because i feel like
i just don't know what the upside is but
it is a pretty pretty freaking
compelling story about that
okay so this i'll tell this story
without giving anything away
um okay let me how do i even explain
this
so there are sometimes i will
we have we have contacts at different
levels of law enforcement that is
absolutely true
and sometimes there will be a reason
to contact either local or federal law
enforcement
because of a voicemail or a call or an
email that we get
sometimes it's like we can do something
good like for example at one point
there was a guy who was leaving
voicemails and he he was saying suicidal
things
and we figured out who it was i found we
figured out the area code
i called the local police department it
was in a totally different part of the
country
they went to do a wellness check the guy
actually
was really crying out for someone to
help they were able to bring him
he got help and a couple weeks later i
heard from this guy and said
i'm so thankful that you called i got
help i needed
okay so that was like that was a good
thing sometimes
we get threats that um
we just say hey this seem this seems
like maybe a dangerous
sort of person and recently
i was notified by one of our federal law
enforcement contracts
that um agents actually showed up
at the home of someone who had been
um sending messages that were
legitimately concerning with with
specific claims
and um they showed up they showed up to
see what's what's going on
and in this particular case they they
said this is a quote the guy was scared
shitless
and it was somebody living in an
insanely rural place
with absolutely no money or the ability
to really
carry out any of what they were saying
not a gun owner
etc um but i'm like i wish i had video
of
you know people showing up uh and saying
we need to talk to you about
you know what i'm not even gonna say
what means they were using to
communicate but what you've been doing
and uh that i mean that's what you what
you want to hear is
this is not someone with the means uh i
think volition is the term that they
used
so that stuff does happen that stuff
does happen
okay let's get to some other super chats
oh actually before i even do that let me
thank a few other people
jennifer wynn is new member number 13
today
glenn moore is number 14 ben francisco
is number 15. laura roche is number
16 and joseph akowitz
is number 17 which i very much
appreciate
we are counting twitch subs today so
once i add in
switch river switch and river me i guess
are the two
uh that actually puts us at 19. and i'm
glad to open phone lines if we uh if we
achieve our goal today as we stand by
for joe biden andreas sends a super chat
and says
i can't watch the paula white clip
without seeing david walk by in the
background yeah i don't have that
available um actually wait maybe i do
let me see if i have that paula white
um
no i don't no i don't but i was sent
this recently this is pretty funny
this is a good uh good memetic element
combining a few different things
frequent question on the phone lines is
this me
and then regularly is an ice cream
sandwich sandwich
is an ice cream sandwich a sandwich or
an ice cream
um and that's a fair question actually
an ice cream sandwich is definitely a
sandwich it is also ice cream so that's
pretty clear
and then i have one other one cappuccino
what is this
oh yeah have you seen it's amazing what
they're doing with latte art these days
these days um that's a that's a
beautiful looking drink i like that
that looks delicious i hope that's whole
milk i found that it's hard to get the
right
texture for latte art with um
low-fat milks i don't know if you guys
have experienced that but i've that's
that i've seen that a lot
okay a kinky turtle says vincent james
is a literal nazi who debated destiny on
guns and brought up race a lot okay yeah
i have no idea who it is
mark says pac-man
miami okay yes yes i'm argentinian is
what this gentleman is asking
in a very coarse way um
yes i am i'm 100 argentinian i'm a
naturalized u.s citizen
all right a couple of other um
let me see what else we've got here
oh i did want to
um do you guys want to see some clips of
trump's 2020
press secretary uh campaign press
secretary talking
this is um 20
trump 2020 national press secretary this
is let's
hear what he had to say this is weird
where's the durham report
you know where are the people being held
accountable who attacked this president
and went after his family
wiretapped and spied on the campaign
well i think that's a good question for
john durham right
what on earth are they talking about
like what what what on earth is that
about
it's bizarre let me just make sure as we
look at these i don't want to miss uh if
we if we get audio we'll go over there
um let's see what other interesting
clips aaron has put together for us
uh oh there's a cringe moment
[Music]
oh my god actually pence running is
pretty
this has to be this guy this is hugely
meme worthy
can anybody do something with this you
know what would be really funny
i don't know if you guys remember the
videos of me when we got our mattress
sponsor i did some videos where i was
diving on the bed
it would be pretty funny to have me
flying by
diving and pence just barely avoiding me
as he runs through let's look at it one
more time
that is an unusual gate gait
very very interesting and then here is
lou dobbs this is a beautiful moment
lou dobbs is interviewing that lunatic
attorney sydney powell
and she starts talking about the future
and lou gets pissed like how come we're
still not
trying to steal the election right now
yes well the american people are going
to have to insist on paper ballots with
real identification
that's going to be one of the questions
that's going to be great i'm not even
i'm
cindy i've got to tell you i'm not even
going to contemplate the next election
i'm not even contemplating the january
5th election in georgia
i like that condom plate c okay spelling
bees
condom plate c-o-n-n-u-m
p-l-a-t-e condom plate
ding oh sorry the hell with that if the
people of georgia are dumb enough
after what they have gone through in the
november third election
to then go toward january 5th and a
runoff and think that changing nothing
will change the outcome right then the
people of georgia aren't half as smart
as i believe them to be see this is the
type of stuff that would
might get georgians just georgia
republicans not to vote which would be
great for democrats
and i believe the patriots in georgia
should stop this nonsense
now it is not something that to be
decided about uh over
who do you favor which party which uh
candidate
this is now about faith in the electoral
system in one specific state
that may control the destiny i thought
it was in four
states this country and by god it's too
important for
anyone and i don't care what party
you're in well you kind of care
i don't care whether you're an
independent oh this is too
important to act as if nothing happened
on november third
and the presidency no that's a funny
thing something did happen
on november 3rd it's that joe biden won
that's what happened
uh it's they don't want to accept
something did happen
we agree something happened just we
don't we don't agree what it is that
took place
uh excuse me thanks to rolly burkink
man with a 10 month sub one of our great
monitor moderators green man rolly burke
inc
green man it's cody galorn
hammer throw stmated cynical gold
switch and river me that's one two three
four five six
seven eight okay uh
19 plus eight nine plus eight is 17
carry the one
one plus one is two 19 plus 8 is 27.
uh got it and then also a thank you to
tanya
poorman bailey
neve janet hamilton
alex burchill new members 28
29 30 and 31
at joinedpakman.com as we stand by
for joe biden a few other super chats
james montalbano says if this scotus
thing is successful
and tens of millions of votes are
overturned in favor of trump the riots
from this summer will look like nothing
well you know there's people predicting
riots
in both cases there's people predicting
riots if by
if if you know the election results
stand and biden is the president
uh it's kind of dark here um what can i
do hold on let me see if i can get a
little more light on
oh that's better that's better um
whoa a lot dude they call it a bunker
for a reason very strange things going
on outside the bunker
uh okay a spooky fox says hey pacman do
you like alfajores conducted
got a recipe for me yeah so i actually
will um
about once a year i'll do alfajores
my sena being cornstarch and it's a
beautiful you make
you basically are making two corn starch
cookies
um and then you put dulce de leche
between them in fact i can show you guys
a picture of what this looks like
this is one of my favorite
[Music]
argentinian pastries
and then you roll it in coconut it's
it's just a perfect
it's absolutely perfect check this out
this is this is a cultural event
i should really be showing a hanukkah
brisket but
is about once a year and it's like a
two-day process because you really need
the dough to sit so first thing is you
make
and bake these uh the the cookie
and then afterwards you put the dulce
election in
and then you roll it in very very finely
minced coconut these are fantastic this
is this is worth a trip to argentina by
itself
um yeah very good so yes i do i do like
them uh
let's see elgato says 11th amendment
read it texas will go nowhere with that
lawsuit of course the
the texas lawsuit is going nowhere i
almost start to feel bad for people who
um it's like you're caught up in a scam
the texas lawsuit is going nowhere
void presence says in mala in monopoly
terms the cult of trump is trying to
flip the table because they didn't win
absolutely nancy casanova
has subscribed at the soyboy level and
upgraded to the beta level very much
appreciate that thank you
thank you did i make latkes last night i
didn't i was actually in transit to the
bunker last night so i was not able to
make them
but if you want to see some beautiful uh
latkes
follow um follow david leibovitz
on instagram he posted some uh
great videos of his latkes
last night and they were they were
absolutely perfect they looked they look
fantastic
okay um
that here so we did sidney powell
um let's see what else we've got
there were a couple of i didn't flag
them specifically i just figured i'd
scroll through
um
where else are we here oh i guess he
hasn't posted that much maybe it was
acen that did
i know that there were other clips i
wanted to play for you guys
we started at the top uh oh let's see
what this is about
this should be interesting our election
has been certified
it's been uh upheld by every port uh in
which it's been challenged it's
outrageous that they filed this and the
oh wait a second are we live oh people
were referring to me sorry okay yeah
let's continue
thought that they would try to
disenfranchise the 39
million people that live in these four
states
it's really disturbing
she says you're trying to disenfranchise
39 million voters in those four states
your argument is that texas voters have
been disenfranchised
do you think the supreme court will
actually take up the case
you know i don't know what's in their
head but what i'm hoping is that we
don't have another place to go this is a
state versus state
so our direct action our first action is
in the u.s supreme court so
most other litigants have the
opportunity to go in front of some court
and be heard at least once
i think we especially in a case that's
this important i think we ought to have
the chance to be heard at least once
can you imagine lower energy than this
and i guess here he says he's not trying
to get a pardon
to answer one accusation in particular
this comes from eric erickson he says
ken paxton the attorney general of texas
is under a federal investigation and
would love a presidential pardon
his lawsuit basically is by someone
desperate to curry favor with president
trump i mean you've long been a
supporter of president trump so how do
you answer that accusation
so eric has no idea what he's talking
about i've been working on these issues
for the last year we've been in we had
12 lawsuits in texas that dealt with
mail-in ballots
that dealt with the voter certification
oh this guy gives me the heebie-jeebies
i'm not going to lie
he just creeps me out very very odd guy
um let's see if there was anything else
here that i wanted to get to
uh oh matt gates let's see what his
claim now is
committee maybe put jerry nadler in
charge of the congressional weight loss
program
jerry nadler in charge of the
congressional weight loss program
okay so it's basically just ad hominem
really really weird stuff matt gates is
just horrible
horrible horrible uh oh let's go here we
go
thank you thank you very much good
afternoon before i
make uh my announcements today i want to
say a few words about the covert crisis
yes this week marked another tragic
milestone in our
fight against covet 19. more than 3
000 deaths in one single day
the highest single death count during
this pandemic
that's more deaths in a single day than
we saw on 911
or at pearl harbor true this is serious
business
and the current director of the cdc said
yesterday
we can expect the similar numbers of
death or more
every single day for the next 60 to 90
days
we're in the teeth for crisis right now
this nation needs presidential
leadership right now
presidential leadership is willing to
model the steps we should be taking
for our to save our own lives and lives
of our families
you know we can wish this away but we
have to face it
head on we have to take it head on
using every power available to me as
president
we'll have a national coordinated
strategy that will that will beat this
virus
you know and as tough as things are now
i firmly believe better days are ahead
we've got some good news yesterday
the fda committed a committee i should
say
recommended emergency use authorization
for pfizer's
bio and tech cova 19 vaccine
but we're grateful for the scientists at
these not only there but other
great organizations researchers who
developed this vaccine and several
others on the way
and we're just as grateful to the
scientists and the public experts
who evaluated its safety and efficiency
free
from political influence i want to make
it clear to the public
you should have confidence in this there
is no political influence these are
first-rate scientists taking their time
looking at all of the elements
that need to be looked at scientific
integrity led us to this point
we know the immense challenges and hard
work ahead
earlier this week i announced our covert
response team
that will scale up the manufacturing
distribution and injection
of the vaccine we set a bold and doable
challenge in my first 100 days
100 million shots in 100 days
asking the american people to wear masks
for
the first 100 days of our administration
right
if we get the necessary funding from
congress
we can get most of our schools open in
100 days but we need the help from the
congress and the funding
the first 100 days won't end to covet 19
but meeting those goals
can slow the spread save lives and get
us back to our lives
with the people we love the most and
we'll also be getting the right people
confirmed
during this period of time and in place
to manage this robust aggressive plan to
contain the virus
help us build back better than ever and
make sure everyone is included
now today i'm really pleased to add
members
to my team that'll get the job done here
we go in addition to the pandemics grim
milestone the economic crisis has left
millions of americans out of work
without a paycheck
without health insurance unable to put
enough food on the table literally
unable to put food in the table
and unsure whether they can pay their
rent for the new when the new year
begins
or make their mortgage payments it's
affecting everyone from
farmers to students seniors to veterans
in red states blue states small towns
and big cities
that's why the congress needs to act and
act now
on the covet package i spoke to my two
friends who are still in the congress
the vice president and the soon-to-be
secretary of hud
we have to get this done they're pushing
hard
but it doesn't look so good right now
but it has to get done before they go
home
millions and millions of americans
simply can't wait any longer
we shouldn't we can't get bogged down on
issues that don't help people
state and local governments need the
help not only that
as i've said for months we need to
protect essential personnel
like law enforcement firefighters to
make you know i interviewed ro connor
recently he says he hopes it does get
done a second stimulus before
the end of the year i just i just don't
know how it's going to happen i don't
see it guys i wish i did even if it gets
passed
but it's an important first step there's
so much we have to do
these crises have ripped the blinders
right off the systemic racism that
exists in america the american people
now can see clearly black latino native
americans nearly three times more likely
to die from covert
and more likely to get get covered to
begin with
black continue black and latino
unemployment rates too hot too large too
high
communities of color are left to ask
whether they'll ever be able to break
the cycle we're in good times
they lie in bad times they're hit
first and the hardest and in recovery
they take the longest to bounce back
vice president-elect harris and i knew
we'd have our work cut out for us when
we got elected
but we also knew we could build a team
that would meet this unique and
challenging moment in american history
some are familiar faces some are new
in their roles all are facing
new circumstances and challenges
that's a good thing they bring deep
experience
and bold new thinking above all they
know how
government should and can work for all
americans
for secretary of agriculture i nominate
tom vilsack
an outstanding two-term governor of iowa
we expected that the best secretary of
agriculture i believe this country has
ever had
he was there when the great recession
was pummeling rural america
over eight years he oversaw a
record-breaking investment to bring us
back
he implemented the recovery act to help
rural communities recover and rebuild
tom helped expand markets around the
world for american farmers he improved
our food
safety standards and helped millions of
children and families receive healthy
meals
he wasn't anxious to come back he wasn't
looking for this job
but i was persistent
and i asked him to serve again in this
role because he knows the usda
inside and out he knows the government
inside now
we need that experience now
one in six americans and a quarter
a quarter of the children in america are
facing
hungary the opioid crisis in rural
america is a rural america crisis
as is a climate crisis with droughts
floods wiping out crops in small
towns farmers and small businesses small
towns rural communities
white black latino are reeling from the
pandemic and economic downturn
tom knows the full range of resources
available to this department
to get immediate relief to those most in
need and address the crises
not one the crises facing rural america
he knows how to build back better for
all americans
he helped develop my rural plan for
america in the campaign
and he now has the dubious distinction
of having it carried out
it's a good plan that includes making
american agriculture the first in the
world to achieve net zero emissions and
create
new sources of income for farmers in the
process nice goal
by paying farmers to put their land in
conservation
plant cover crops it use the soil to
capture carbon
and will ensure that usda promotes true
racial equality and inclusion he
recognizes the history of discrimination
and will root it out wherever it exists
i've known tom for a long time and i'm
confident he'll get it done
for secretary of housing and urban
develop i am i am
really pleased to nominate congresswoman
marcia fudge
who might add could do many jobs beyond
the one i'm asking you to do that's an
interesting picture i think the job i'm
asking you to do congresswoman is
critically important to everything that
the vice president i believe is how
we're going to build back better
as a former mayor she understands how to
manage challenges and forge solutions at
a local level
for 12 years in congress she's
represented the great city of cleveland
you know uh though i think of her most
significant political feat was being
elected president of deltas
i know from this state how powerful the
deltas are
you think i'm kidding i'm not
she developed an entire career for
fighting for working people on issues
from affordable housing
to urban revitalization during the great
recession
her district was hit hard by the housing
crisis
she spent the past decade working to
improve blighted neighborhoods
create safer more affordable communities
she also understands where you live
impacts on your health
access to education jobs and economic
opportunity
zip code should not determine the
outcomes on all those issues
she's going to bring that same vision as
hud's secretary using
every lever at her disposal to help the
millions of americans facing
it's refreshing not to hear uh the the
president president-elect
assail the character of people during
every every single presentation
charged to make housing more affordable
and
accessible should work to increase home
ownership
as a means towards the wealth generation
particularly for communities of culture
culture communities of color it's not
just
dealing with the other issues we have to
be able to build
wealth in communities of color
and she's also going to help us build
back better by working across the
ideological spectrum
to fulfill the promise of hud's mission
and here's what his mission is it's
often forgotten
to create strong sustainable inclusive
communities
and quality affordable homes for all
and a quote marshall be the first woman
to lead hud in more than 40 years
and just the second black woman ever i'm
honored to have her serve and thank her
for being willing to do it
in the biden harris administration
at this critical moment in our nation's
history
and for secretary of veterans affairs i
nominate dennis mcdonough
former white house chief of staff deputy
national security advisor
deep experience on capitol hill i've
known dennis for a long
time he shares my belief probably the
type of person you want in that role
we have only one truly sacred obligation
to prepare and equip our troops that we
send into harm's way and then to care
for them
and their families when they return he
regularly traveled as i did to iraq and
afghanistan
to meet directly with our service
members to see what they were going
through
to understand the strain and the impact
on them and their families
he'd visit them as i did often at walter
reed to see
firsthand the visible and invisible
wounds
they brought home he knows the cost of
war on veterans and their families
from the toll on their physical and
mental health to the access to good
paying jobs
and he's a fierce advocate and a
relentless workhorse
and i believe and i think everyone who's
ever worked with knows he's a
world-class manager
with an innate understanding of how
government can and must
work for our veterans he worked closely
with our then va secretary bob mcdonnell
and with the congress to increase va
funding to ensure veterans to get the
benefits they earned and they deserve
and by the way
he knows we have a very very steep hill
to climb in getting
more funding more docs more
psychiatric nurses more folks out of the
private sector
into into the va that includes
implementing veterans choice a bill led
by my friend bernie sanders
and my late friend american hero john
mccain
and signed into law by president obama
in 2014 to help veterans
access quality health care that they
need when they need it
and in this role i've given dennis a
clear mission
fight like hell fight like hell for our
veterans and their families
and anyone anyone who's worked with
dennis will tell you
he'll move heaven and earth to fix any
problem get a job done
he'll also work closely with our
secretary of designated
uh secretary of defense designated lloyd
austin and the entire cabinet
as and jill as first lady to pull every
leader
every lever to help us build back the va
better than ever
and dennis yeah it's a family endeavor
his wife kari leads a non-profit that
helps connect veterans and military
families
in local with local communities so they
can help each other out
and build a stronger country together
we're both uh both our spouses
feel incredibly strongly about this and
have for some time
all the veterans and military families
nominating a va secretary is one of the
most important decisions
i believe a president can make and
dennis will always be there for you i
promise you
always fighting for it as will the vice
president and i
for the united states trade
representative who nominated catherine
ty
this light is really weird i apologize
everybody
a dedicated public servant who knows
government and who spent
her career leveling the playing field
for american workers and their families
that's not hyperbole that's a fact she's
currently served as a chief lawyer on
trade for the powerful house ways and
means committee
praise from both lawmakers and
both political parties and from both
labor and
business as well now that's a feat
across the board but all kidding aside
you have i've got more calls
complimenting me on your appointment
than you can imagine
during the obama bite administration she
was the chief trade enforcer against
unfair trade practices by
china which will be a key priority in
the biden harris administration
understands that we need a more
strategic
to be considerably more strategic than
we've been
and how we trade and that makes us all
stronger how we're made stronger by
trade
one that leaves nobody behind she can
work closely with my economic and
national security and foreign policy
teams
trade will be a critical pillar in our
ability to build back better
and carry out our foreign policy foreign
policy
for the middle class when i announced my
candidacy i talked about a foreign
policy
for the middle class and i meant that in
a literal sense
she also brings a sophisticated
understanding of the threats of climate
change to trade as well as addresses the
climate crisis with urgency she also
bodies a powerful immigration story of
america
her parents were both born in china they
moved to taiwan and then came to the
united states where katherine was born
her prayers became government trump's
not going to like that he wants to be
punishing chinese people at this point
hiring their daughter to pursue a career
in public service
catherine says she's the first american
board member
born member of a family and a second
generation u.s
government servant that's a great way of
expressing it
if confirmed she'd be the first asian
american the first woman of color to
serve in this position
in our nation our economy our workers
our businesses
we fortunate to have her serve in this
role
as director of the white house domestic
policy council
i spent some time convincing this
wonderful
public servant but we are i'm appointing
susan rice former there it is united
states ambassador to the united nations
former national security adviser to
president obama
former academy member team player policy
heavyweight through
tough negotiation we'll be breaking all
of this down on monday
who i've known for a long time not only
admired but become friends with she'll
lead
and coordinate my critical domestic
policy agenda
and she's going to elevate and turbo
charge a revitalized domestic
policy council to help us build back
better on every issue across
the board she worked closely with my
director
national economic council brian dees she
worked closely with my national security
advisor jake sullivan
and the national security council
together they'll align domestic
policy economic policy and national
security
unlike ever before this is a big and
critical role
that's why i asked susan to serve she's
been there
she knows what it takes like she did in
helping mobilize the entire federal
government to end the ebola crisis
and her voice is particularly needed at
this critical moment
the granddaughter of immigrants
descendant of enslaved people
susan will be an effective and tireless
champion
for all americans and she knows i'm
really thrilled
she was willing to come back be at my
side in the white house
to each of you on this team
you have my gratitude the gratitude of
the vice president of me for answering
the call to serve again
to your families thank you we know the
sacrifice
you're making to allow your family
member
to serve as they are going to god
willing
and to career civil servants at these
agencies
we look forward to working with you
because we know how many talented people
are there
it's time to rededicate ourselves to the
mission
our government agencies were entrusted
with
and to the american people help is on
the way
i promise we're not going to let you
down
may god bless you and may god protect
our troops and now i'm going to turn
this over to the team
starting with our next secretary of
agriculture tom vilsack
tom thank you should be interesting
you're going to do a little cleaning
there um no real surprising picks i
think marsha fudge is sort of the most
interesting one and there's a lot of um
i've seen more talk about that one than
anything else i mean tom vilsack will be
fine it's not controversial
uh it is sort of just a return to you
know
uh the the the previous um let's take a
listen
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
i'm honored by the trust that you placed
in me to return to the vital work
of the usda at a very critical moment
for so many families and communities
throughout america
and to begin that work by embracing the
full benefits
of a diverse and inclusive senior
leadership team
in the department as i was proud to do
in my previous tenure
and to continue the important work of
rooting out inequities
and systemic racism in the systems we
govern
and the programs we lead when abraham
lincoln
established the department of
agriculture he called it the
people's department i look forward
to making good on that moniker for all
people
as we build back better so everybody's
using that at this point i'm going to be
celebrating a birthday on sunday
one of those round numbers that causes
you to reflect on your life
he must be almost 50. thinking back on
the path of my life
where it began in an orphanage in
pittsburgh pennsylvania
to iowa where my incredible wife christy
and i raised our family
and the home we've made there to
standing here today
being given a chance to serve our
country once again
i feel enormously lucky and grateful
to live in a country where my paths like
mine
are possible a country as the
president-elect
often says is defined by possibilities
but unfortunately and tragically not all
have experienced those possibilities so
i consider it my duty
and my responsibility to help expand
those possibilities for
all america lot of possibilities there
i know firsthand the character of the
dedicated public servants
who work hard each and every day to
fulfill the mission
of that department and i'm especially
grateful
for the chance to get back to work
alongside them
one of our first charges will need to be
to contribute
all we can as a department to aid in the
dynamic response
reviving rural communities and economies
addressing dire food shortages and
getting workers
and producers the relief they need to
hang on
and to come back stronger
when we emerge from this crisis we're
going to have an incredible opportunity
before us to position american
agriculture
to lead our nation and the world in
combating climate change
and reaping the new good-paying jobs and
agriculture is actually super
interesting because agriculture goes
through
uh issues of systemic racism and
inequality
access to food hunger
um climate energy
transportation like it's it's actually a
huge deal and
a super interesting position to let a
lot of people just like oh aggregate
what you you deal with corn somewhere
maybe
the poverty line for 30 years or more
and to ensure that every child in our
country
and all those who are in need have
access to safe
affordable and nutritious food
we need to build back a vibrant and
resilient rural economy
that creates new possibilities for
manufacturing workers
for family forest owners for farmers
ranchers and producers
that helps to make life better and
richer for them
and safer for all of us and under my
watch
the usda will be a team player working
with our sister agencies
to advance issues of shared interest
from rebuilding our infrastructure
to fixing a broken immigration system to
combating and fighting the opioid crisis
i look forward to pursuing that work
opportunity to serve uh people asking
what's going on with the lighting
i'm uh it's just the it the sun is
setting very early
um on the east coast right now and it's
just
it's just kind of a mess i'm in the
bunker today and it's just very weird
i do believe i'm getting vitamin d right
now though
mr president-elect my good friend
madam vice president ila to my family
my friends my sorority sisters my
constituents all
i thank you for the opportunity to join
this remarkable team and work on behalf
of people
in every city and community to serve all
those who are struggling and looking for
the fair shot
we all deserve when i think about the
enormity of the task ahead of us
i am reminded of the book of matthew
where it is written
foxes have holes birds have nests but
the son of man has no place to lay his
head
there is dignity and there is grace
within every woman every man and every
child in this nation
including those who live on the
outskirts of hope
those who work hard but still struggle
to make it work
and those who have no place to lay their
head
it is one of the highest
responsibilities of our government
to see them to see their dignity
and to lift them up i remember the
feeling i had as a kid
of the safety security and peace of mind
contained in one word home
i remember the comfort of knowing that
no matter what happened
i could always go home but far too many
americans live without that feeling
more and more have had that comfort
ripped away
the crisis of a pandemic that has
threatened their lives i think i'm
getting sunburned crisis of a recession
that has swallowed up jobs hours wages
and lifelines
the crisis of injustice that has forced
communities of color
to make it in america with one dream
tied behind their back
each crisis chips away at their hope
at the promise of our nation but i
believe that hope is on the way
because i know that president-elect and
vice president-elect are building a team
that is grounded in dignity and our task
at the department of
housing and human development urban
development will be to stand up for the
dignity of all americans
and deliver the promise of our nation to
all those left out in the cold
we will take on the deep set roots of
poverty
and homelessness we will fight for
housing in every community
that is affordable decent and safe
we will help more americans secure the
dream of homeownership
to close the gaps of inequity build
wealth
and pass it on to their children we will
pursue
creative development projects to shape
our landscapes and skylines
restart the engines of cities that have
stalled out
and launch new opportunities in home
towns across america
but perhaps most importantly
of all we will help people believe once
again
that their government cares about them
no matter who they are
that we understand their problems as the
president-elect
often recalls his father's words i am
honored to have this chance
to help restore the people's faith to
deliver for them and make them proud
and to build back better alongside this
dedicated team
i thank you for the opportunity to serve
all very very normal and low-key in the
middle of the worst moment of the
pandemic
cleaning of the podium happening between
folks
saving the n95 for the cleaning guy
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
i'm deeply humbled by the trust and
confidence you have placed in me
and if confirmed by the senate will be
honored to serve
as the secretary of veterans affairs mr
president-elect you have pledged to
restore the soul of our nation and to
unite us as americans
in this work there is a mission that can
bring every american
together caring for our nation's
veterans
and their families as you have said this
is a sacred
obligation and i know it's that for you
and dr biden it's also
very deeply personal i've been inspired
by
veterans in my life as well
today i'm thinking of my grandpa
mcdonough a marine
all the troops i met on my visits to
afghanistan and iraq
and the wounded warriors i spent time
with at walter reed
are showing around the white house i'm
thinking of the many vets i've had the
pleasure to serve with
in and out of government who have put
the character and training that they
developed in uniform
to work to continue serving our country
as civilians
i'm also thinking of one of my high
school football coaches back in
stillwater minnesota
in iowa joe sam samuels
he stormed the beaches of normandy and
in home hospice at the end of his life
he and his family were grateful for the
compassion
of the va when he passed
his wife gave me his coaching jacket one
of my most most
prized possessions coach sam's jacket
reminds me why when they come home
we need to have their back
as the president-elect has said his
march marching order to me
is very clear fight like hell for our
veterans
we're going to fight like hell to give
our veterans and their families the
health care
respect and dignity they deserve
that means helping our veterans build
civilian lives of meaning and
opportunity
making our va even more welcoming to all
veterans
including our women veterans veterans of
color
and lgbtq veterans
and keeping faith with our incredible
military families and caregivers
because we need to have their backs too
to the men and women of the va many of
you veterans
yourselves you work tirelessly to
take care of our veterans and your
demanding jobs have been made
even more difficult by the pandemic
to you and to the many dedicated vets
service organizations
who include vets survivors and their
families
i look forward to being your partner
one united team and delivering care and
support
that's second to none finally
taking care of our veterans is not a job
for the va alone
every federal department and agency has
a role to play
and i will fight like hell to make that
happen and even though only one percent
of americans
wear the uniform under president biden
every american will be called upon to
embrace our responsibility
to support our veterans and our military
families
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
on behalf of my wife kari and our family
thank you for this opportunity to serve
may god bless our troops our veterans
and their families
and as a nation may we always
give them our very best just as they
have done for us
thanks very much as apollo cyrus is
pointing out in twitch chat this
is definitely a change in tone
um and style from the trump era
and also in substance from the trump era
it is really only a change
in style going back further and it will
be very similar to under the obama era
mr president-elect
madam vice president-elect i'm grateful
for this opportunity to serve
and look forward to working with you
with our partners across the
administration
and with the bright and dedicated public
servants at ustr
to deliver for the american people
when the president-elect approached me
about taking on this role
two memories from my past spring to mind
the first was from when i initially
joined ustr in 2007.
i was filling out paperwork and
providing information about my family
history
my parents were born in mainland china
and grew up
in taiwan in the 1960s president
kennedy's immigration reforms
welcomed them to america as graduate
students
in the sciences my dad would become
a researcher at walter reed helping the
army
advance treatments for afflictions that
debilitated american gis
fighting in the vietnam war my mom still
works at the national institutes of
health
developing treatments for opioid
addiction
they were naturalized in 1979 five years
after i was born in connecticut
and it wasn't until decades later
filling out that paperwork
that it occurred to me that i became an
american
before my parents the very first one of
the funniest things about these pics
is you've got the left is so unsatisfied
with the these are just
the very center-left obama-era type
folks
while the right is saying biden will
usher in socialism and communism and
it's like
obviously both sides can be displeased
but
only one side is right and there's
nothing socialistic or communistic about
any of these people
and my heart swelled with pride as we
raised our placard and stated
that we were there to present the case
on behalf of the united states of
america
two daughters of immigrants there to
serve
to fight for and to reflect the nation
that had opened doors of hope and
opportunity
to our families those memories fill me
with gratitude
for being an american and for what
america is
at our best and they remind me of the
extraordinary by the way it's not lost
on me the irony
that we have six times as many people
watching our stream
of this than joe biden actually has
watching it on his official stream
any other tool in our domestic or
foreign policy
it is not an end in itself it is a means
to create more hope and opportunity
for people and it only succeeds
when the humanity and dignity of every
american
and of all people lie at the heart of
our approach
i am proud to join with leaders who
instill their policy with purpose
and who never lose sight of the humanity
and dignity
the opportunity and hope that make trade
a force
for good in our nation and the world
i am very proud to be an advocate for
american workers
to stand up for their ingenuity and
their innovation
and for america's interests across the
globe
i look forward to harnessing the power
of our trade relationships
to help communities lift themselves out
of the current crisis
and i am grateful for this chance to
serve fight for
and reflect america on behalf of all of
our people
once again thank you
nothing too notable or remarkable we'll
do deep dives into the policy
backgrounds of these folks we'll have a
report
monday or tuesday um and i think we have
just one more person we're going to hear
from
how come tulsi isn't on the cabinet guys
thank you so much mr president-elect
madam vice president-elect i'm honored
to join this tremendous team today we
confront
a profoundly connected set of crises
a relentless pandemic a struggling
economy
urgent demands for racial equity and
justice
a climate in need of healing a democracy
in need of repair and a world
in need of renewed american leadership
in the 21st century our foreign
economic and domestic imperatives
are deeply intertwined
tackling these challenges is personal to
me
i'm a descendant of immigrants and the
enslaved
and service is in our blood
my paternal great grandfather was born
by the way people are saying that i
should just look at a few minutes of the
news max live stream when this is over
just to like see the insanity that's
going on i i'm going to do that so so
there's only one more speaker i believe
the bordentown school
in new jersey which for seven decades
provided
african americans with vocational and
college preparatory
educations two generations later
my father emmett rice served as a
tuskegee airman
and as a governor of the federal reserve
my maternal grandparents came to this
country from jamaica
with no education but working for
decades
as a janitor and a maid they saved and
they scraped to send
all five of their children to college
for people asking me if these picks are
good or bad
um these pics are exactly what we would
expect
and they're way better than what we saw
under donald trump
and they will be scandal-free relatively
and completely predictable and
relatively
not exciting for a progressive from
portland maine
but today for far too many
the american dream has become an empty
promise
a cruel mockery of lives held back by
barriers
new and old that is not good enough
yeah and none of them are socialist
communists or marxists i should add
we know that throughout our history
americans have
forged opportunity out of crisis
after the civil war we ended slavery and
enshrined the concept
of equal protection under the law
during the great depression we
established the works progress
administration
and civilian conservation corps after
world war ii
we enacted the gi bill in the 19th
century
and none are part of biden's family as
is being pointed out established full
voting rights
and enacted medicare and medicaid
now at the foot of yet another bridge
between crisis and opportunity i'm
honored and excited to take on this
role joe biden and kamala harris's
vision
for our future is expansive
but achievable america must finally
become
a nation where every child from
akron to arkansas from the bronx
to brownsville from the sioux nation to
south central los angeles
can dream without limits and make
her dreams come true i have no illusions
about the difficulty of making that
vision real
but we are here to get hard stuff done
our top priorities will be to help end
the pandemic
and revitalize the economy so that it
delivers
for all to bring dignity and humanity
to our broken immigration system to
advance racial equity
justice and civil rights for all
to ensure that health care is accessible
and affordable and to educate and train
americans to compete and thrive
in the 21st century i profoundly believe
that we all rise or fall together
absolutely all of us so mr
president-elect
madam vice president-elect i promise you
i will do everything i can to help this
country i love
to build back better to make our
government
deliver for all americans right and for
working families
and to bring the american dream far
closer
to reality for all
thank you very much there is
susan rice and then
um i guess we will very briefly hear
from kamala harris
and then this event is going to wrap
then we're going to look at a little bit
of news max
momentarily
good afternoon over these past few
days and weeks we have announced members
of our administration
who will help us meet the unprecedented
challenges
facing the american people we have
brought together
a health care team that will help
contain this pandemic once
and for all an economic team that will
help
build an economy that works for working
people
and all those looking to work and a
national security and foreign policy
team
that will help keep our nation safe
and restore and advance our leadership
around the world today we are announcing
leaders
who will help deliver immediate relief
to every corner of our great country
from rural communities
to big cities and every place in between
leaders who will help care for our
veterans and
their families an advanced opportunity
for all americans at this consequential
moment
in our country by the way my phone's
going off that there i guess tim poole
and adam baldwin that right-wing baldwin
are going crazy because of a tweet
i made about voter fraud we'll look at
it after this is over my phone is
exploding right now
hungry in the united states of america
at a time when one in six renters are
behind on rent
we need leaders who will not only help
provide relief to all who need it
but help address the affordable housing
crisis in america
you know i was in high school by the
time my mother
saved up enough money to put down a down
payment on the home
and i understand the dignity of
homeownership
and the importance of making the
american dream
i find this type of like wrap up very
meaningless and kind of a waste of time
but i don't want to like cut it off
rudely presented in california
have been strained by almost two decades
of war
and economic hardship we must have
leaders
who will treat all who have worn our
nation's uniform
and their families with the dignity and
respect
they have earned leaders who will be
focused on doing what is in the best
interests of the american people
who will negotiate trade deals that are
good for workers
and good for our economy who will
address the defining challenges of our
time
from combating our climate crisis to
advancing racial justice
that is what these remarkable americans
will do
i know them well and some are very dear
friends
these leaders have different backgrounds
and life's experience
and they bring to their roles different
skills perspectives
and areas of expertise and
they all reflect the very best
of our nation they are all dedicated and
compassionate public servants
and all of them are ready to hit the
ground running
on day one so mr president-elect
congratulations on these outstanding
choices
i look forward to working with each
member of the team
and the whole team that we are bringing
together to meet the urgent challenges
facing our nation
and to rebuild our country in a way that
lifts up
all americans thank you
and it looks like uh that is it okay so
more pics
uh for joe biden his full cabinet is
coming together i will have the full
details on
um on monday so let's look at a couple
of other things right now
so earlier uh let me just refresh here
now that we're on dim
mode earlier i tweet so this i'm gonna
i'm gonna try to figure out what's going
on along with you guys okay
earlier i tweeted the following voter
fraud is essentially a religious belief
you believe it and then look for
evidence and the only
evidence comes from those who already
believe it when confronted about lack of
independent evidence this is sort of
like when confronted with evidence from
outside the bible that the bible is a
religious
is an accurate sacred text you claim
well
others can't definitively prove it
didn't happen okay so i just tweeted
this on a whim a couple of hours ago
and i'm told that the quote tweets that
people are going bonkers
let's see here um
i wish there was a way to just do
verified only because i'm looking for
some specific verified
do you guys know i don't want to pull up
my tweet deck is there any way that i
can just
look at um responses
and retweets from verified accounts okay
so there's this daniel bostick who
produces
the plot against the president who says
this
except for denying voter fraud exists
okay that's weird
um but where is the baldwin and tim
poole stuff bear with me because i think
this is pretty interesting
the baldwin one isn't even showing up
that's strange he must have done it
in some different way let's look at hold
on
adam baldwin
oh i missed it oh i'm sorry okay hold on
uh we'll find it this way
let me see if i control f my own name
pacman
no now i can't see it what the hell is
going on here
i scrolled past baldwin all right let me
go back i'm sorry
i'm not the best with this stuff let me
see baldwin
aldon's not showing up now
maybe it didn't load
oh wait here it is okay tim poole lol
right on cue like david said uh uh
okay so tim poole said i have personally
corroborated
evidence of double voting i don't know
what that means did he double vote
himself
so again the point is is
when when you have 160 million people
vote
there will be errors and you may find a
handful of bad actors who are typically
republicans but
you know they they it this this has gone
from i don't know what he even meant by
this but
it's like there was fraud that would
have overturned five states
so that biden would lose to i have
corroborated evidence of double voting
like so
how many votes is that um and then i
guess someone
responded and then deleted and tim said
just like david said na uh i just don't
care guys
it's just like but biden just won that's
all it's super simple
um that's adorable now go find a new
grift
that's pretty funny all right let's look
for the baldwin one now
okay i'm still not finding it
show more replies
baldwin baldwin still not finding it
did he delete it i don't even know at
this point
let me see if i can find it on my phone
go to quote tweets i thought i was on
quote tweets jeez
okay now let's see baldwin is still not
showing oh there it is
okay oh okay so adam baldwin just said
election fraud denialism
um who which is he is this guy related
to the baldwins i just know this guy's a
right winger but i don't even remember
who this guy
is nobody knows
okay all right well what you know it's
like
guys i don't care you know um
a great um a great arbiter of ideas
named
dave rubin once said twitter is not real
life
and that is uh that is exactly right so
anyway this was the tweet that i guess
while i was streaming sent some right
wingers into a uh
into a tizzy but it's it's pretty pretty
unremarkable
okay so that's that let me now get to
folks wanted me to check out um what's
going on on newsmax i'm glad to do that
as well
let me just get caught up just briefly
here monique robertson
signed up at joinedpakman.com and so did
kevin brown that puts me at 45
and then we're counting twitch subs as
well we have combo carl who just signed
up
ill albert who also signed up and that
puts us at
47. okay very good let's just see
just to dive in for a second i believe
newsmax is going to be a big piece
oh so let me explain why we're going to
look at this oh this has to be a parody
it's important you're now entitled to
eliminate co-pays
and get dental care dentures eyeglasses
prescription coverage in-home age why do
they go
so big with the teeth i don't get it
like i have no problem with people
getting dental work i
i think that that's a great thing but
how do you get talked into going
so big with them is what i don't
understand it's like
do the teeth i'm with it i'm with it
just get a normal size
i just don't understand that i will i
will not get it uh
okay so i think that
we are going to see right wing media be
crazier than ever during
the next few years why are we going to
see that
they learned during the obama era that
stuff like
birtherism and benghazi
and you know lies about nancy pelosi all
this stuff
the crazier you can go the more
profitable it is
okay and rachel maddow made a really
really
interesting um uh gave a really
interesting explanation when she was
interviewed by uh the daily show guy
whose name i forget i've not
i've never seen the daily show a full
episode since jon stewart left and i
forget the guy noah
trevor noah um rachel maddow said that
there's a reason
why the left is never going to be as
engaging as the right on the the media
because
one of the things we do on the left is i
say hey listen i'm one voice
and sometimes i don't get every detail
or get every detail correct
and there's great reporting going on
from the new york times and the
washington post
and you know look at these economists
and look at these historians and do all
this different stuff
fact check me let's all work together to
keep
zeroing in on the right thing one thing
that right wing media does
is they say we tell you the truth and
everything else is fake
you've got to come here for the truth
and it slides
where now you even have newsmax and oan
saying
we tell you the truth fox news won't
even tell you the truth what's the truth
fox news won't tell you
fox news during the day acknowledges joe
biden one
so the profitability and
you know trump now is promoting oan and
fox and and
newsmax so i think during uh this isn't
about memes there's great memeing on
both sides that's for sure
but i think we're going to see
right-wing media be crazier than ever
during the next uh during the next few
years so anyway i'm just curiou we're
just going to dive in this is like
sam cedar's old segment random rush
where he would just listen to a few
seconds 90 seconds of rush limbaugh
randomly
let's just see when the mike when the
mike lindell my my pillow ads are over
let's just see like what they're
covering what they're talking about i'm
very very
curious about that thanks to penny
bluebell for subscribing on twitch do
you think
we have a chance of a full party split
on both sides
opening up a proper multi-party system
or is the democratic system on the way
out thanks to this insanity
we will not so the the right may well
fracture
into sort of like the mitt romney side
and the newsmax side is maybe the way to
describe it
um but we're not going to get real real
multi-party representation in any
significant way
until we change campaign finance and we
change first past the post voting
but i appreciate the the sub thanks to
averroes
as well those are um subscribers
48 and 49 today you know someone
suggested something to me they said you
know david
um i use stream labs for live streaming
someone said
you can have pop-up up there everybody
who follows on twitch and subscribes on
youtube
and so everybody can see their name come
up i think that there's too many to make
it viable like i don't even think i
could keep up in reading them
i just think that that blue box up there
would get stuffed
the entire stream i don't know that
makes any sense it's like just
in the last minute it's like amanda
gentry subscribed on youtube
john person sent a super chat minix
followed me on twitch
see missile gifted some subs penny
bluebell signed up
john person super chatted daddy halton
subscribed turtle subscribed scroll guts
followed
kelsey marchman sent this i i don't
think it's it's uh plausible
let's take a listen here secretary of
state has now been
docketed by the u.s or with the u.s
supreme court can you explain to us a
little bit more
what that means and what this particular
lawsuit involves
large suit well thank you for having me
back on
uh the lawsuit was documented today yeah
i filed it
uh so i guess what they're pretending
they might win georgia that's the
takeaway to go through before they can
officially docket a case
and at least preliminarily it means that
the petition met some of the essential
requirements
such as page length word count they've
got the page length
correct so that's step one in turning
over georgia the page length
they've submitted regular pages uh it
it raises in my case the exact same
issues
with respect to the georgia election
that are asserted
by the state of texas in its litigation
but i found my case just a few days
after the election
when i realized that some reason the
republican party was not acting
and i decided that on behalf of we the
people i'm trying to imagine like what
type of person is sitting at home
saying uh i believe joe biden didn't
really win
and fox won't tell me the truth anymore
uh
and biden seems to be picking cabinet
members but i don't believe that
these aren't people who are ever going
to be cabinet members what i believe is
i'm going to sit here and watch newsmax
because lynn wood
is about to overturn this thing uh
because i refuse to give up on it
because i think i'm right
and so i petitioned for the red of
cersei roy to the supreme court
and uh yeah i can only hope that the
justices will decide to take the case
and if they do i believe they'll follow
the law and they'll rule that the
georgia election
who is this unlawful and
unconstitutional
because it was based on a deal cut by
the secretary of state with the
democratic party
oh so now now he's saying the republican
secretary of state cut it
that's fascinating so now that it's now
that republicans in georgia the governor
and the secretary of state are saying
like we can't really just give the
election to biden
now the conspiracy is that those
republicans cut a deal with the
democrats
governors are due for the last two or
three weeks
and they'll have to decide what to do
with an invalid or unlawful election
depending on the time i would like to
think they have time to
select electors that would vote for
president trump in the
electoral college okay and then so
that's the remedy they're looking for
which is even though biden won georgia
send republican electors anyway which is
uh
really crazy instead of this january
5th runoff that's based on an illegal
election
and is subject to fraud that they'll
have time to set a new down ballot
election in georgia so that we can get
an honest vote can you imagine
and have a person running
or elected that has not been elected or
lost on november the third based on
fraud
this is about all of it i can take guys
i think okay we've seen what's happening
on newsmax
i'm willing to take a quick look at oan
let me just find that live stream oh
hold on
oan live um
i don't even know how this is allowed
now that youtube said this stuff is not
allowed anymore
like you can't make live streams or
content
i guess oin is not live you can't do
stuff that denies that joe biden
actually won how i don't even know how
that live stream is even allowed
but let's just pick a random clip from
the last 24 hours
how about um let's see
um let's do swalwell in bed with china
let's see what this is about
on the issue and how congress can
respond is representative russ falcher
who probably serves the first
district of idaho so congressman we were
just breaking down the axios report
about representative eric swalwell do
you have any concerns about him
currently serving on the house
intelligence committee
you know i really do china is our enemy
and they are real they have
an economy that's arguably as large as
ours they have a military that's
arguably as large as ours and what just
happened
with the small well situation is
kind of a wake-up call so i i hope
people understand
nothing happened with eric swalwell it
um about
seven to ten years ago seven and nine
years ago um
eric swalwell was in touch with someone
that we now know
was apparently in the united states um
[Music]
sort of like um it's not really working
for china but like
at the direction of it wasn't a chinese
spy per se it was someone doing
influence and trying to kind of
ingratiate themselves with
those in positions of power and it's a
woman who
recommended a certain intern for eric
swalwell's california
office and the fbi went to swalwell at
the time
and they said this person is sort of
like a pseudo
a chinese intelligence person that may
even be too generous
and swalwell said oh holy [ __ ] i had no
idea
like i'll cooperate with whatever you
need me to do
and at no point has he even been accused
of wrongdoing
and now that it has been it has gone
public that this investigation took
place which involved swalwell and like a
couple mayors and all these different
people
um now they're like oh my god swalwell
by the way who what relevance does
swalwell have swalwell in bed with china
is the
the subject here this is just how in
depth
the chinese will go to try to infiltrate
american influence
so this is very troubling number one
because he's a member of the united
states congress
number two because he serves on the
intelligence community has tremendous
access to information
yeah and i think that's very well put
because for example he's not the first
individual it wasn't too long ago we
were talking about dianne feinstein who
had a driver on her staff
who was also a chinese spy but we've
also heard this taking place
at uh our academic institutions across
the country so now these are completely
different things so so okay wait a
second
so academic institutions that that
and chinese spy i mean this is crazy but
the the point is
you know the point is when we say that
there's all sorts of different ways in
which foreign countries will meddle
including what russia did in 2016
it's a real thing nobody's denying that
but the question is did dianne feinstein
do anything wrong or did eric swalwell
do anything wrong
institutions across the country earlier
this week there was a videotape
of a very wealthy chinese individual who
was saying that they have
some people in the highest places of
power here in the us
how can we address these concerns in a
very tangible way
the this is a global issue that's been
going on for a hundred years
right the infiltration
with intelligence officers deep cover
agents
uh it has nothing to there's no
bla it's not the democrat it's not the
fault of democrats it's very very
strange because now they're
they're acting like this is evidence of
this is a global issue
we do it in other countries other
countries do it here
other countries do it in other countries
it's it's very strange
well first of all the university issue
is a is a serious one i've had concerns
about this
for a long time we run the risk every
time we
import our students from other countries
oh they're saying its students could be
the intelligence officers that's
interesting
uh i don't know if there's any evidence
of that what's this this guy is alex
salvi let's see who that is whoops
alexa salvi alex salvi
um yeah i have no idea i don't know
anything about this i don't know who
these people are
uh but again i we're doing this because
i predict that oan and newsmax will be
players
in setting the propaganda agenda for the
next few years
okay anchor on oan i don't know i don't
know anything about him
uh all right very good well we looked at
it um and as
as people asked for i appreciate
everybody joining me um
we will keep up with the streams we will
be back with a full week of shows next
week and streams i'll be doing
live coverage of a bunch of different
things including
here's what i want to ask you guys about
if on monday there is
actually a live stream of the official
electoral vote taking place because
that's monday december 14th
if there's something for me to cover i
would love to stream live
it's just not clear to me that there's
actually an event to take
that that i could cover um so if anybody
can find out about that and email me
through my website contact form
uh i'm available and i was planning on
working
you know kind of scheduling my day
around that so that i could cover that
for everybody and we could see like
joe biden has officially won i think
that that would be great
i will cover that please email me
through my contact form on the website
be back with everybody very soon